so unfortunately it's become very toxic
now to talk about what's going on with
russia and ukraine and there's almost no
assertion that can be made
without someone popping up out of the
woodwork and saying no no no no
that's uh a tanky talking point or
that's an imperialist talking point or
whatever even relatively
uncontroversial
statements like putin likes to play
games with his aggression it's like you
know who could possibly deny something
like that uh but someone is lying and
there is some truth and i don't think we
really know it and unfortunately what
has become very toxic about discussing
the russia ukraine story
is that
uh
any claim
triggers someone into saying you are
playing a role for x y or z
um side or perspective or enclave or
whatever the case may be
this gets us to the latest news which is
well on the one hand we were told
that vladimir putin and russia were
pulling troops back from the ukrainian
border
that would be a great thing if it were
true making it less likely that there is
going to be an invasion unfortunately
nato and the us and ukraine and others
say not only is russia not pulling back
they seem to actually be building up
troops even further now someone is lying
both can't be true um and i guess
theoretically the way that
you you could have
sort of some technical truth to both
would be there has been some pullback in
one area near the ukrainian border
with a buildup elsewhere and then both
sort of may be true but the spirit of it
of course is like overall is russia
moving towards ukraine or away from it
there's a new reuters report which says
west warns military buildup near ukraine
growing not shrinking that's very direct
and very clear estonia says russia
likely to launch a limited attack russia
releases video showing tanks leaving
crimea ukraine defense ministry hack
worst of its kind says government and
there's a question as to whether russia
is responsible for that hack um there's
a growing russian military presence at
ukraine's borders western countries
warned on wednesday as estonia said
battle groups were moving ahead of a
likely attack to occupy key terrain
contradicts contradicting moscow's
insistence of a pullback more armored
vehicles helicopters and a field
hospital have been spotted
britain's defense intelligence chief
said in rare public comments up to 7 000
more troops have moved to the border in
recent days including some arriving on
wednesday a senior official in biden's
administration said without providing
evidence so there are people who will
say we can't trust biden we can't trust
nato anything they say simply cannot be
believed
they're just straight up lying obviously
putin is
pulling back from ukraine
it doesn't seem obvious and uh i think
the other part of this situation that's
gotten difficult and this is just it's
if i sound bummed out it's because i am
that this has now become
almost like a uh it's sort of like a
venezuela type situation for some on the
revolutionary left
where there's this wing of the left that
ends up i mean the right is totally gone
cuckoo i'm not even addressing them
right now but there's this wing of the
left that ends up
in their desire to always oppose
american imperialism and american
intelligence
they will end up
supporting
um and defaulting to believing
authoritarian strong men around the
world and we saw this with venezuela
where if you say hey you know uh
the stated populist ideals of
chavez and now maduro
are just window dressing for
authoritarianism
and the pillaging of the country's
resources for the gain of the elites and
honor if you say that you're
wow you're you're an american
imperialist no what did i say about
wanting the u.s involved in any way i
said nothing about that
but that's how you're branded and
unfortunately if you say hey you know
putin's intentions may not be all on the
up and up here uh similar allegations
fly and unfortunately or
i don't i don't even know if it's a
question of fortune but
speaking realistically we don't really
know vladimir putin's intentions here
his intention may be to invade ukraine
his intention may be not to invade
ukraine but to goad the west into doing
something which will give him a leg up
in negotiating a
position in the future putin's intention
may be to do this to rattle western
stock markets which it has been doing
like if that were putin's goal it has
succeeded i do not think we really know
and what we do know from history is it's
unclear why anyone would believe putin
absent real solid evidence the video of
tanks moving in one direction doesn't
really tell us definitively what is
going on that video could be could be
anything could have been filmed anytime
uh it quite literally is of no value
whatsoever and uh we know that trump
believed putin right like when putin
told trump we didn't hack anybody trump
immediately immediately came out and
said listen i asked him did you hack us
and he was very strong in his denial and
i believe him okay well so we know trump
believed putin most people don't believe
putin unless they have independently
verified the things that vladimir putin
is saying so that's where we are
um one last thing from dw
nato fears russia is seeking pretext to
attack ukraine that's another idea which
is what putin is doing
is to
cause ukraine to do something which will
then justify the invasion and that's why
we see the back and forth so we're not
going to know maybe for another day
maybe for another week we don't know but
anybody telling you
this is the ultimate and definitive
truth on what putin intends to do be
skeptical of that be skeptical of that
because we don't know
and anybody
telling you i mean it's a very trumpian
thing which we'll sometimes hear from
those on the revolutionary left you say
i you can only tr i know the real thing
anything else you're hearing can't be
trusted this is the one definitive
explanation and analysis be skeptical of
that
uh you you will do you will do well to
remain skeptical of of those such uh
claims
there is a insane new video of rudy
giuliani we talked about rudy giuliani
earlier in the week and just like do we
feel bad for him do we not a lot of his
current problems are really of his own
doing choosing to get involved with
trump and choosing to defend trump and
choosing to fly around the country
filing these bogus complaints and
holding bogus hearings related to the
2020 election and rudy giuliani is
potentially in a bunch of trouble now
he still appears to be sort of
maintaining his loyalty to trump at
least for now even though for most
reports we've seen trump has more or
less abandoned rudy giuliani and the
latest is that rudy giuliani claims to
have evidence
related to hillary clinton in either his
bedroom or his den now then we could
talk about is a den a living room but
maybe without a television or how do we
define den doesn't really matter rudy
says on newsmax he has evidence in his
bedroom and then he says actually it's
in my den and everything about this is
really weird because it is essentially a
confession from rudy giuliani which i
will explain
huffpost reports rudy giuliani reveals
location of secret evidence stash the
former new york city mayor makes a weird
confession on live tv giuliani declared
tuesday he has a stash of secret
evidence against former secretary of
state hillary clinton and it's in his
bedroom and then he says actually it's
in my den this was an interview on the
right-wing news max network he says he
has a thousand pieces of evidence that
no one has seen
and of course as you might remember
rudy giuliani's
home and rudy giuliani's office were
raided and so if there is quote evidence
there it raises the question as to did
he legally
hold that back or hide it in some way
here is rudy on newsmax explaining to us
exactly where the evidence is
well i don't think trump uh knew i knew
about it back then
i can't tell you exactly how but i know
how he knew about it back then there's a
lot more to come out uh
this is not i mean what you're
they may feel that it's gobbledygook
but it's gotta be supported by about a
thousand pieces of evidence none of
which have been revealed yet wow i
happen to have it in my bedroom
or my den actually
had it there for years as well
so so there's a bunch of different
things here and it all is the continued
self-inflicted damage being done by rudy
giuliani first question did he break the
law by withholding this supposed
evidence like this is if if he if the
evidence exists right and i know you
guys all the first thing is is this even
in the
universe of truth
if it is did rudy giuliani break the law
by withholding this supposed evidence
that's question number one
uh second question
is he willing to present this supposed
evidence
in court while under oath because all of
these guys and gals for years claim to
have all of this evidence here there the
other place it's always imminently going
to be released and this will be hillary
clinton's undoing or this will be joe
biden's undoing or this will be the
vindication of trump we've got the
evidence
and then it never actually gets released
or presented or introduced in any kind
of serious way under oath in a court of
law or submitted as an exhibit and it's
very common for these right-wingers to
claim they have evidence and that it's
it's just about to come out and then we
never see it and look at what happened
with the 2020 election they've been
claiming on the 2020 election that they
have evidence that's gonna just blow the
socks off of this election it'll flip
arizona it'll flip michigan it'll flip
georgia it's it's
mind-blowing what they have they've been
claiming it for 15 months and it never
does and if they have it they've also
not included it in any of the court
filings related to the 2020 election all
of which are found to be without merit
um and it's very similar with other
liars and grifters mike pillow mike
lindell the ceo of mypillow
he has mountains of evidence he has
cyber evidence he has forensic evidence
voting machine all of this different
stuff and nobody has seen it
nobody has seen it so
then you have to step step back and
think about the political
donald trump has been running against
hillary clinton since 2015 and he
continues to run against her even though
he's not running for anything and she's
not running for anything he continues
the hillary clinton stuff do any of us
believe
that if rudy giuliani had a thousand
pieces of evidence against hillary
clinton
it wouldn't have come out when trump was
actually running against her
come on guys it doesn't make any sense
and this stuff plays really well on the
conservative news channels but obviously
they would have used the evidence if
they had it at any time during the 2016
campaign during the 2020 campaign
recently the goal right now is
distraction and distortion things are
not looking good for giuliani things it
hasn't been a particularly good week to
two weeks for donald trump what with the
flushing documents done down the toilet
and all of these other different things
and it is obfuscation distraction
distortion look at this shiny thing i
claim exists but there's no evidence it
actually does if you believe
that rudy genuinely has evidence
about anything honestly at this point
find me on twitter at d pacman and let
me know what you think he has but more
importantly
why he has not yet released it i look
forward to hearing from you
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
okay we're gonna look today at a few
clips uh and listen to a few clips from
a recent interview that candice owens
did with uh eric trump or i guess i
guess eric trump did the interview with
candace owens candice is the interviewer
is the point i'm trying to make and what
i want you to think about here
uh are really two things there's two
takeaways here you know candace owens is
this uh right-wing grifter it's not even
clear she's really right-wing it seems
that this is a a business model that she
stumbled across uh uh she claims that
she used to be on the left now she's on
the right the explanation never really
makes sense this really seems to be
mostly a business thing for her and she
will say anything i mean she said after
bob saget died seems like it was related
to the vaccine of course it was there
was no evidence of that and now we know
that it was actually um you know a hit
to the head
uh
absolutely no standards she will go
lower doesn't matter she will say
anything that that will get attention
she interviewed eric trump
and there's a couple different things to
pay attention to here one is
this interview
you this is so important to understand
this interview counts as
deep serious intellectual discourse for
the right and for republicans at this
point in time now i assert that this is
the epitome of pablum i mean this this
is trash worthless discussion but also
look at the way in which they pander in
this particular first clip we're going
to look at to the religious wing of the
republican party but in such a
transparent way that not
you you would have to suspend all
disbelief and skepticism to think that
eric trump is even remotely serious
about his religiosity here so let's just
jump right in you're it'll all be be
made very clear here you can have dinner
with anybody dead or alive you can't say
trump you can't well you are trump but
you can't say your father i've already
had dinner with him
plenty of times how about jesus jesus
okay so jesus is who eric if he could
pick anybody to have dinner with he
would have dinner with jesus now we all
know this is not a religious family
trump didn't go to church uh his kids
didn't go to church this is a character
they've developed since entering
republican politics but what gives it
away
is this next part take a listen good
answer that'd be a good one right what
would you ask them oh god
did you envision this happening to the
united states of america and
did you ever envision a person as
incompetent as joe biden running the
united states of america how in the
world did this happen right you can tell
how deeply spiritual he is from the
question he would ask jesus and of
course at all
this is the
uh uh sort of sofist facade that these
guys and gals try to put up there well
there's no one other jesus is the top
person i would like to have dinner with
really
and what would you ask him not what is
the meaning of life what is the origin
of the universe what you know not
why why does uh why does god allow bad
things to happen no the question would
be
did you ever imagine an incompetent joe
biden would be the president of the
united states that's the one question
you ask jesus if you sit down with him
it's unbelievable i mean it's who could
possibly fall for this stuff but they
see this and they go this is a religious
family this is deep intellectual
discussion i honestly i might ask him if
this is actually a ploy to show people
the difference between republican
leadership and democratic leadership
like
sometimes god selected biden to show how
much better republicans are that's
that's obviously the concern of jesus
think about that you know is is this
part of the
yeah you have donald trump who had just
four years of despite all everything
they tried to do to destroy him
again you know greatest unemployment
manufacturing was coming back to this
country remember this this is still all
what would you ask jesus you know a
stability in the middle east the likes
of which we've never seen before and you
just go through all the accomplishments
and then
in
about three weeks this guy comes in and
you've got you know gas prices double
and you have inflation absolutely
through the roof and you have
the loss of civil liberties i mean not
only should you ask jesus about gas
prices ask about his view on leaded
versus unleaded and ask about ethanol
too you have crime going through the
roof you've got christmas presents that
can't be delivered because larry's store
shelves are empty because okay so you
guys get it so this this counts as
serious discussion on the right and then
it it gets even crazier where eric trump
says that the covet vaccine represents
the stripping of freedoms in the country
in a literal sense
okay
the vaccine which his dad invented
according to what they say
and should get praised for also is the
literal stripping of our freedoms the
problem i have with it is
it's contradictory to their own message
which is wrong like you've got to be
consistent in life you know you can't
waver every single day but i think
beyond that it's a greater reflection on
kind of where we are
as america if they're willing to strip
your rights to your own health care or
what are they willing to do a religion
what are they willing to do the second
amendment what are they willing to do
to our constitution really a deep
thinker as you guys can tell
and i think even candace owen seems
bored by this by the way if you're
watching we all know the answer to those
questions right and it's deeply scary
but to me the vaccine actually
represents something that's
much greater than a medical shot to me
the vaccine represents literally
the stripping of freedoms
in this country which is now all of a
sudden candace owens perks up now she's
nodding yeah oh yeah the vaccine that's
it is the stripping of freedoms exactly
this guy's obviously vaccinated like the
whole trump family like trump himself he
knows it works he got the vaccine but
this is the red meat to stay on message
which is deeply deeply deeply troubling
and you see it every single day you see
it as they rip down these statues of you
know thomas jefferson abraham lincoln
and george washington all over
the country now why are they doing that
right like why are they
why are they ripping down statues
because they want to rewrite our history
they want to rewrite you know our simple
liberties even this is like a distortion
because you guys know and we've we've
followed
the the overwhelming i don't even know
maybe a lincoln statue was taken down i
don't know i've certainly not heard of
it maybe a washington stat i don't know
anything i've not heard that
but the whole statue controversy was
really about confederate statues and
schools named after pro-slavery
confederate generals that's really what
this was about but they can't say that
trump sometimes would talk about it but
they can't really say that so they say
they're trying to erase abe lincoln but
all of this is a distortion all of it we
want to rewrite our constitution so if
they can make the very people that they
rip down they can make them martyrs
well then they can make the documents
that they wrote and to kind of
you know martyr documents they can
change those documents right it gives
them
the reability you know the ability so
anyway as you can tell eric trump is not
the smart one he's not the articulate
one what he's saying is making no sense
and i guess he's trying to say if you
take a lincoln statue down it justifies
changing the constitution and of course
the argument about constitutional
originalism or the constitution as a
dynamic document that should be
considered in the context of the modern
world it has nothing to do with lincoln
statues but they see this this is the
type of you know
90 of the discourse on the right is now
crt bad it's okay to be white dr seuss
is good
elmo big bird whatever the thing that's
90 of it the other 10
is this type of thing which to them is
like as serious a discussion as you will
get now i am not advocating for the
political views of the people i'm about
to name
but just to tell you guys that it wasn't
always like this
go on youtube and look up
william f buckley
and some of his debates go and look up
thomas sowell i'm not saying these are
people whose views i agree with i'm just
giving you examples of the fact that
there used to be a different type of
thinking on the right where you could
engage substantively on issues
more the way that you know yesterday
when i spoke to former republican
congressman joe walsh we were sort of
able to do to some degree
it doesn't have to be this stuff but
that's all that's left at this point in
time and if it if it works for them if
it wins them elections i can't imagine
any real reason that they would change
that all right before we go to a break
we talked this week about glenn beck's
reactionary fear porn as we talked about
it on yesterday's show we also talked
this week about donald trump floating
the idea of the death penalty
for people who
he believes i guess committed crimes
related to
spying on his campaign which is not at
all what was uh um claimed by the durham
report and this has become its own sort
of echo chamber story um donald trump
appeared this week on the glenn beck
program and on that program again he
talked about you know
we we used to kill the people that did
the things that hillary's people are
accused of doing as far as he's
concerned let's take a look at just a
little bit of this
so the biggest scandal was when they
spied on my campaign they spied on my
career there's no real evidence of that
of course there is it's all over the
place
leslie they spy to my campaign and they
get caught can i say something
you know this is 60 minutes
and we can't put on things we can't
verify turn it on because it's bad for
abiding we can't put on things we can't
verify leslie they spied on my campaign
and we can't verify i'm totally verified
no
it's been just go down and get the
papers
they spied on my camp the papers he
flushed maybe and they got caught no and
then they went much further than that
and they got caught and you will see
that leslie and you know that but you
just don't want to know
as a matter of fact i don't know that
[Music]
okay so that was a that was from 60
minutes uh years ago and of course
leslie stahl was right there was no
evidence of what trump was claiming but
now glenn beck is going to pretend there
is
we just don't have the facts well leslie
now you do and president trump is here
to discuss perhaps why uh cbs and
everybody else is not talking about this
welcome to the pro they're not talking
about it because fox news and right-wing
media have created a false story
uh and there is nothing to talk about
that's the reality program president
donald trump
well thank you glenn great to be with
you
thank you so uh this is this is pretty
amazing um you were right when you said
this is worse than a watergate this is
far worse than watergate and it's not we
don't seem to have anybody in the
mainstream media that cares about it at
all
well in watergate they broke into an
apartment in watergate and they
took some things and
nothing good about it and it turned out
to be a disaster
this is far bigger they
broke into my campaign and all of that
but perhaps most importantly they
they broke into
the oval office they broke into the
white house
at the highest levels
so illegal
and as you know being somebody that
knows history probably better than
almost anyone else
uh that would have been
uh a short time ago it would have been
considered treason
and i agree you know what treason is
punishable by uh
and a longer time ago it would have been
punishable by death
when there it is again
we were in a tough country
yeah
i wonder if
i wonder if there's going to be any
punishment at all um with this i mean
hillary clinton uh okay
so remember the people trump is talking
about
have not been accused
never mind charged with any crime and
trump is talking about the death penalty
what happened here is that right wing
media and the trumpian
wing of the republican party exploded
because of a court filing from special
counsel john durham
what they are saying trump and others
is that the
uh there is definitive proof in the
filing
that democrats
i guess directed by hillary clinton
illegally spied on trump in 2016 and in
2017. the truth is the filing does not
allege espionage it says a
clinton-linked
lawyer clinton-linked lawyer and you
have to then actually prove
whether there was any active link
between them at the time it just
associated with hillary clinton
historically
obtained
non-public data from the white house and
trump's servers now
if it happened
as described
and you can indicate that a crime was
committed then the lawyer should be
charged
if you believe that there is an actual
operational link to hillary clinton then
you should demonstrate it and if there's
criminal liability okay but so you you
see we're already three or four levels
removed here and um there is no actual
evidence from the durham report there's
almost first of all nothing new in the
durham report
it's not an indictment it doesn't
criminal conduct
it basically is an issue of conflict of
interest and what john durham is saying
is we we've discovered here a potential
conflict of interest
there's this lawyer sussman he worked at
the law firm perkins coy perkins coy
represents the dnc hillary's a democrat
there's a potential conflict of interest
here that that's what this is
fundamentally about so far and i got a
couple of emails from people in the
audience saying david why haven't you
covered this fox news is all over it fox
news is making you think hillary's about
to get arrested and indicted and
imprisoned uh she's not
and again trump is talking about the
death penalty for people who have not
even been accused of a crime we're
talking about conflict of interest at
this point in time so that's what it is
if you want to see the clip trump glenn
beck we'll have it on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman's
show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show today we're going to
be speaking with edward miller who's a
professor at northeastern university
also author of the book a conspiratorial
life robert welch the john birch society
and the revolution of american
conservatism really appreciate your time
today
oh it's my pleasure it's a great
opportunity to
to discuss the book and
uh
to talk with you
yeah so to start with you know we've
been thinking a lot about this line in
conservatism that got
us to where we are today and we could
sort of start that story at a lot of
different points in time
um i think an interesting place to start
might might be if we go back to robert
welch and the john birch society to
start kind of creating our understanding
of how things got to be the way they are
uh
who who was robert welch and and talk
about his relevance to modern day
conservatism a little bit
well robert welch was a candy
manufacturer from
the south he was originally from north
carolina
and he was a very successful candy
manufacturer he created such childhood
favorites as the
sugar daddy and the junior mints
and he um
he decided it was his career was done
for
uh making money and then he decided to
get involved in
uh anti-communist activity and establish
an organization called the john birch
society uh this organization tended to
be of a conspiracy
conspiratorial bent
uh with the major highlight being that
welch believed that president eisenhower
was a communist which of course is
is ridiculous uh but
uh he continued to establish this john
birch society and it and it and it
became the
the most powerful anti-communist
organization in the
in the early 1960s late 1950s
and as i argue in the book
had influence even into the 70s during
the
the um the age of reagan
of which we're probably still in and
when we think about the
mccarthy era and and sort of that
reactionary fear-mongering basis on
which you know we we need to be
suspicious of people with certain
ideologies and we need hearings etc
that paradigm in different forms has has
really persisted throughout the 20th
century and into the 21st among the
american right wing has it not
oh absolutely the
um
the the claims of
treason
that are that were echoed by mccarthy
uh that were echoed by uh william jenner
he was another another senator
uh that were echoed by william noland
these these kind of um
aspersions continue on into the
republican party in in the present
it didn't have to go this way in the
sense that i mean i think an interesting
anecdote is william f buckley who we
don't have to be fans of his or praise
him or anything to to recognize that
buckley's instincts were very much
antithetical to the idea of welch i
think in my understanding and this kind
of red scare type stuff where buckley
seemed to think that the right was going
to do better by taking a sort of less
reactionary
approach is that accurate and why i mean
did did that succeed for a period of
time until it again reversed or what's
the history of that
i think it succeeded for a brief period
of time but
buckley was an excellent order
and historian he was a gatekeeper of the
far right and
he was also i mean this was his pet
project to create the conservative
movement of the
uh of the 20th century
and
he saw a threat to the conspiratorial
behavior
in the john birch society and he
concluded that it was best that john
burt that
robert welch leave the organization or
be settled as he said into the uh
editorial room where he could do less
damage
and um
for for a long time we thought that
historians we thought that
uh
buckley had excommunicated welch but i
began to take a look at
uh what was going on and what the john
birch society had done
uh after the period that they were
uh traditionally known as being in exile
the period 66 to 68 but i found that i
found in my research that welch changed
the organization
focused on ad hoc
issues uh through ad hoc committees
and push pushed issues that became
consonant with the reagan revolution
issues such as abortion
issues such as
the equal rights amendment anti-taxation
issues these all became
a part of the
um
part of the fabric of the of the reagan
revolution
and it pushed that the reagan revolution
in that particular direction
in the 1970s so i
i found that welch welch was more
significant than we thought
it seems to me that
had the sort of buckley wing won out
you would not have seen maybe the tea
party
the trump wave
q and on even a lot of the kind of
modern outcroppings of this the
anti-vaxx it it
i mean i guess we can't say for sure but
it seems that those movements follow
much more from the conspiratorial welch
side than from maybe what buckley wanted
well it's of course we can't we
historically it's a tough um yes the
tough um
uh we we can't determine with exactitude
that that would happen uh conspiratorial
thinking has become more popular in our
uh in our culture
ever since watergate and the 1970s when
um when the church committee came out as
as
when the iran contra affair
occurred in the 1980s when
um the you had figures like alex jones
and rush limbaugh in the 1990s
um pushing their
um
their views
but i i think it's true that if it was
um if it was just buckley and and welch
was not part of the
uh part of the
the scene it probably would have been a
lot different
i'm curious to what degree the realities
of media and the development of the
internet uh had as as a role in all this
there's this book waves of rancor which
is sort of a look at uh
you know the history of how did talk
radio and am radio become right-wing and
the connection between uh churches and
like low-power religious radio you know
a lot of this nitty-gritty stuff but it
seems to me
that
the more conspiratorial
welch
type thinking
lent itself much better to
the radio space and media space than
maybe what buckley
was more known for and i wonder to what
degree the realities of media influence
the direction of the american right
oh i think without a doubt the the in
the influence of the
of talk radio especially after
um
the fa the end of the fairness doctrine
um
you definitely see an increase in
conspiratorial thinking if you if you
take a look at
um
how
rush limbaugh phrases
uh conspiratorial thinking on his show
he would just
allude to something in the facts
um you know and say well this is what i
read in the facts to avoid libel or
something like that uh but
uh he did imply this conspiratorial
thinking very very
casually along with michael savage and
and
other
um
other conservative radio hosts
uh who had who had
adopted that tradition glenn beck
so these figures are important as well i
i'm not
diminishing their role but before all
this comes
robert welch who is setting up
this uh
this way of thinking this different way
of thinking and he is
uh joined by
other radio
uh folks like dan smoot
who is a
uh a dallas-based former fbi
g-man
who worked for
h.l hunt who comes to his own conclusion
and
concludes that
it was not a communist conspiracy per
say that was driving things but an anti
but a globalist conspiracy yes that
which is part of the
um
part of the language that you see in in
stephen bannon's um politics today
speaking of not of a not of a conspiracy
of communism but of globalists and
internationalists and and welch was
speaking that language
by the end of his life as well yeah i
mean i i'm do is it fair to say that
right now the american right is as
conspiratorial as it's ever been as
indicated by i mean you know recent
polls of republicans more than half
believe trump is actually the winner of
the 2020 election
the degree to which they question
whether vaccines work whether covet is
real or you know what however we define
is
is there any time at which the bulk of
the republican party believed things
like this
i can't i can't in my in my knowledge of
all of all the time in the 1980s and
1970s and 60s i think the early 60s
there was a significant um
uh
belief in that particular direction
the um
but i i think that the pen the
combination of the pandemic
um and
uh
the um the the
trump's refusal to admit the reality
that he lost the presidential election
uh and
his willingness to tout this to his his
base continue to tout it to his base
has had a a significant impact so
what can reverse the course of a
movement that is so committed to that
type of thinking um i mean i think you
know to some degree if they start losing
they would probably be forced into
rethinking it i i guess
uh but i mean what sort of forces can
really turn around a movement like that
well i i always but
you know i i always
this is a great question and i always
consider this myself when you know i'm
encountered with somebody who has a
different perspective of
from how i look at
how i would look at something
that i would see as
not nefarious you know i would just see
it as the mistakes of individuals or
let's take the loss of
the loss of china
in the 1950s in the 19 after 1949 many
republicans were blaming
the democrats for the loss of china and
they were focusing on the treason of
elected officials uh dean atchison and
george marshall
even um even harry truman
and they were pinpointing
welch included were pinpointing that um
truman was a traitor
or at least atchison and marshall were
traders in this
process
i'm more apt to see
individual mistakes
and
the fact that
the chinese people had decided on
chiang kai-shek
uh in that particular case so i i look
at it
as an opportunity each time to talk to
people on a personal level and try to
speak to them about this the history of
it
and
you know if that doesn't work
right right i mean i think the question
that a lot of people are kind of
grappling with and looking at the
direction of the republican party over
the last six years in particular and
then even even just a little bit longer
is sort of like what's the kind of end
game here and part of it may be that
this is just an indefinite means like
there there's there's not necessarily an
end in the sense of you know earlier in
the week we looked on the show at a clip
of glenn beck recently interviewing
james lindsey where they're talking in
extreme like it's almost like a modern
red scare type language about they're
going to put us if we're not in cages we
have to be ready to resist and it's just
like it could be applied to anything
it's like are you talking about vaccines
or democrats or
uh
china or like what it almost is just
this universal language that's not super
clear but you're supposed to be very
scared about it um and it seems almost
like it's just a means to its own
self-preservation rather than to some
end
yeah i would agree i think
i listened to a lot of the the you know
the far-right shows because it's part of
my job and yeah
if you hear some of the things coming
out of mike lindell of the the pillow
guy yep
for instance he's
he's still trying to overturn the
ballots and um yeah i've interviewed him
and i'll tell you he seems to be a true
believer i mean in my conversation with
him off air he seems to really believe
this stuff
oh okay so you've talked with him oh
yeah
oh yeah wow
um that's fascinating it was it was
i i would yes i would put him down as a
true believer and i would put robert
welch down as a true believer i i have
nose um after reading
this book i have no sense that this was
done
for
um
histrionics he wasn't doing this to earn
money he gave he gave every cent
of his um of his millions
to
um to fight windmills in a sense he was
the don quixote of um
of of the conservative movement uh
and
but there are still
folks who are committed to
um this
canard
that we see as a canard and
uh
but
how to deal with that i think we're all
wrestling with that yeah
it remains an open question uh for for
sure um the book is a conspiratorial
life robert welch the john birch society
and the revolution of american
conservatism we've been speaking with
the book's author northeastern
university professor edward miller
really appreciate your insights today
oh it was a great pleasure i i very much
enjoyed it
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
let's talk a little bit about the
canadian trucker convoy um this is you
know it's it's uh i don't want to say
rare but it's not super common that
something that really starts in canada
and remains in canada for so long
becomes such a major u.s story the u.s
is very u.s centric as many of you i'm
sure know
but part of the reason why the canadian
trucker convoy has become such a big
story in the united states is that it's
become sort of a pet issue
for right-wing media right-wing media
has been supporting and inciting the
trucker convoy making them out to be
heroes if you look on twitter there's
all sorts of folks including
former leftists and right-wingers and so
on and so forth saying this is just it's
incredible freedom these people are just
doing an incredible thing
never mentioning the radical right-wing
nationalist and xenophobic
roots and organizers involved in the
canadian trucker convoy not mentioning
that
many of the mandates that they are
supposedly protesting against are being
slowly dropped anyway as uh
as sort of logical based on what's going
on with covet numbers they're not doing
any of that stuff
uh but this week something very
interesting happened which is that on
the fox news program the five geraldo
rivera who
i'm not like a fan of geraldo he was a
trump guy
um he said a lot of things that don't
make any sense but every once in a while
geraldo will
it's a broken clock that's right uh
every once in a while
he will call out fox when they are
peddling disinformation or inciting or
spreading propaganda or whatever and
geraldo had the audacity i guess we
would say to tell the people on the five
you guys have been inciting these
protests you guys have been inciting
they don't have that much support in
canada let's take a look at it and the
panel very very triggered by geraldo
killing it well you know as it relates
to that
trudeau in order to i understand that in
order to
uh to use this national public emergency
act parliament has to put his imprimatur
on it so
no within within two weeks parliament
has to vote on it uh my understanding is
he's not that popular in canada how is
he going to put bring this to an end you
know it is not that popular in canada
judge is this trucker this freedom
convoy right what about the freedom of
the honor homeowners to live in peace
what about the freedom of the shop
keepers to do business what about the
freedom of the geraldo
when it's black lives matter or
and the nebulous antifa protesting
that's when you care about traffic
people getting to work businesses etc
when it's the trucker convoy you don't
you're not supposed to care about it
auto workers to get parts so they can
say that's when they were burning down
the federal courthouse in seattle
i did more than that i condemned it and
the funny thing is that line plays well
whoa judge jeanine really got him on his
hypocrisy no geraldo has been clear no
matter who's protesting he doesn't want
destruction of property uh fires
blocking traffic whatever condemn
anybody who who feels so he did it
but what violence are they so empowered
that they can take away your rights to
establish their rights what rights are
they taking away they're taking away the
right of the homeowner to sleep in peace
the writer the shopkeeper to do business
it is conservative media that is that is
has gone from support to incitement um
are violating the rights of others in
canada the the are you saying we're
inside the polls that i see the hub
ledger ipsos these polls all show
between 65 and 69 percent of canadians
opposed through these truckers true
because this has gone on long enough oh
that's supposed to show the evidence
yeah they have a very short open your
eyes and look no no i'm actually i
actually read and do research yeah well
the research seems to have confused greg
gutfeld very very significantly but her
aldo is absolutely right and then they
start fighting about
who is actually more working class in
this entire thing if they were to stop
roll backs justin trudeau used these
workers for a year
yes two years excuse me and made them go
to work every day call them essential
basically didn't provide them with what
they needed and then in one stroke of a
pen now how funny is that because that's
what we did in the united states too
under trump make them go to work don't
give them the things they need except by
you know it's like pulling teeth but
they they were defending trump's
handling of covet one day said actually
you're no longer essential workers yeah
now you're non-essential yeah it's very
rude but i gotta regret it i have to
respond to this thing because geraldo
says blanketed right-wing media is
inciting and it's essentially he's also
implicating us because we aren't
defending that dare you yeah that's
exactly right that and geraldo is
correct to do so
i'm okay with that because the fact is
we've always been on the right side we
are not like the right side we're not
the right
you're on the political right but not on
the correct side you geraldo which has a
disdain for the working class
no no i am your working yeah in that
bentley right go drive into your your
after 50 years of hard work and you have
more charity than you'll ever do in your
entire life my point is you don't like
these guys coming up first
the i you know geraldo has a lot of
flaws he really does but the idea that
the reason geraldo thinks the canadian
trucker convoy is nuts is because he at
i mean how old is geraldo at this point
he's got to be close to 80. yeah 78 the
idea that now 78 year old geraldo who
has
you know accumulated assets during the
course of his life the reason that he's
opposed to the canadian trucker convoy
and the inciting of the trucker convoy
by fox news is because
he drives a bentley if that's true or
because he has now has assets there is
no evidence of that whatsoever and it's
just so funny to hear these very people
who when it's convenient they support
the rich guy from queens and they don't
talk about how trump's totally
disconnected from the average
working-class american when it's
convenient they ignore that but then
when it's convenient they'll say well
geraldo drives a bentley and her aldo
really struck a chord here he's
absolutely right that these folks have
been inciting and at the end of the day
the the canadian trucker convoy is a
reactionary movement it's it's a
reactionary movement they
they want to go to the status quo
merely for the previous status quo
merely because that's what it was they
don't want vaccine requirements they
don't they don't want anything and of
course these things are going to fall
off as we're already seeing them fall
off but um that that you know what the
police by the way oh i should even
mention that
there's a video which i'll play here
without audio
of canadian police shaking hands and
hugging the trucker convoy people when
you have the support of the police as
well as of capital in your movement
you have to consider that it's a
reactionary movement and it's not always
the case and i want to be careful about
making blanket statements but the idea
that this is some kind of
you know working class uprising
representing the predominant opinion in
canada there is not a single poll that
suggests that that's what it is and some
of the main insiders of this entire
thing have been american right-wing
media okay one little funny like coda
onto the canadian trucker
story
my pillow ceo mike lindell has been
barred from entering canada this is it's
you couldn't script it you couldn't
script it if you if you included this in
a screenplay of this entire thing it
would be now it's not believable
mike pillow as we know him
has been on this propaganda campaign to
deliver pillows to the truckers okay
and
he sent a truck
which i guess got held up at the border
some some kind of customs thing but then
pillow tried to go to canada and he was
turned away because he was not fully
vaccinated and didn't have a negative
pcr test according to a government
source it's beyond parody and he knew
the rules or at least he should have
known the rules if he didn't and um of
course this was what was going to happen
but he was not allowed into canada the
funniest thing would have been
if he did get allowed in because he
actually is vaccinated you know how some
of these right-wingers i mean eric trump
we looked at earlier in the show
they attack vaccines they criticize
vaccines but they're almost certainly
all vaccinated it would have been like
the perfect cherry on top
if pillow was actually vaccinated
despite claiming to be against the
vaccine and the latest thing that he's
going to try to do
is to drop the pillows from the sky
uh to the truckers
after his initial tuesday shipment of my
pillow products was denied entry into
canada
pillow now has a backup plan to get the
pillows to the truckers drop them from
the sky via a helicopter
um
it's not clear that that's actually even
going to be a possibility as well
the mic pillow thing is it's a tragic
comedy it really is like all he had to
do was keep selling pillows on tv and he
would be doing fine but he had to mix
politics he's making commercials now
about being canceled his bank has
canceled his uh account because of
reputational damage that they worry
about and i got a ton of messages from
canadians in our audience saying david
please keep your nut jobs in the united
states i have no interest in sending
pillow to canada
trust me i have nothing to do with this
but just the the final sort of bizarre
detail
uh with the mike pillow saga we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p yesterday i spoke about jamie
raskin the democratic congressman as a
potential uh democratic presidential
candidate were joe biden not to run many
of you liked it but many of you agree
the fact that raskin is jewish will make
it an uphill battle for him many of you
acknowledging that here is the eggman
agreeing with that
hey dave i really love jamie raskin too
he's a total mint that's why he's not
gonna ever be nominated for president he
could never win we need somebody sketchy
and somebody with more
uh skeletons in their closet nobody like
him
somebody less jewish did i say that
shalom brother yeah yeah no i mean i
think
it's it's very clear that in the current
environment
raskin would have to deal with a lot of
anti-jewish sentiment if he were to run
but there is i mean i know eggman's
being funny
raskin seems so clean like maybe he does
have skeletons in his closet and i don't
know about them
but you tend to need someone
with a history of like off-color remarks
which become the source of controversy
or
family drama or whatever i mean raskin's
story is just sad i mean when one of his
one of his kids died actually died died
by suicide um but he doesn't seem to
have the types of skeletons in his
closet that uh seem almost ubiquitous
in uh in american politics we've got a
great bonus show for you today the texas
attorney general is now suing over the
biden airport and airplane mass mandate
could this be the next thing to fall
a woman has been cured of hiv
thanks to a stem cell transplant and the
justice department is suing missouri
over a new gun law we'll talk about all
of those stories on today's bonus show
sign up at
joinpackman.com to get instant access i
will see you then
you